so i want to start with uh if someone
has actually never seen
anything that you've done what is the
first thing you want them watching and
why
oh god um
that's a that's an interesting question
i don't know i i think i would
maybe
suggest the very last picture i've done
just so they know what it looked like
and then
show them pictures from like 20 years
ago when i was super cute
oh i mean i i
i was going to say i think i think you
still look okay no thanks i think you
landed on your feet
so jumping into um uh this film
specifically uh i i am a big fan of this
film because of putting all of these
kick-ass women together it's always men
who are in these movies and i love that
it's just a bunch of you know women
kicking ass i'm assuming this is what
immediately drew you to this film
yeah that and um
just you know it felt refreshing to see
women kick ass but in a in a
in a way that wasn't so on the nose you
know like oh look at us we were like
these super feminist
you know girls that are fighting for
the girls you know we're it's just like
uh
we're
we're in a genre that is typically male
but we're making a movie that you know
could be the same if it was with men i
guess you know what i'm saying it's not
a feminist movie per se
um i know that uh the beginning of the
shoot you guys were in paris and you
were filming in locations that are
typically not used which is the paris
underground near
where there was actual train tracks with
the third rail you know like uh yeah so
talk a little bit about filming in the
paris underground and were you at all
nervous to be down there
i wasn't nervous but you know i lived in
france for 25 years and i make a lot of
french movies and i never got to shoot
down there and
it was super fun for me to be
in a way home and
and and shoot in those places you know a
big american movie is is always
a novelty in paris for sure and the big
boulevards got locked off and you know
riding a motorcycle through paris um
like that was so exhilarating and then
yeah running in those tracks in the
subway was super cool
uh jessica was the person who put this
all together producer coast star uh what
maybe surprised you about working with
her that you maybe you weren't expecting
ah you know i i didn't know what to
expect to be honest i'd known her over
the years and i always thought that she
was uh you know very kind and
i always admired her as an actress
i thought she's a really
wonderful producer because i think she
made the experience and the work
environment for us
women
so much better and i think it's
something that she's always wanted for
herself you know meaning in the sense of
equal pay
um
having a space for our families on set
you know having a trailer that was
just there for child care and being able
to
the hours that she kept
the way she treated the other actresses
you know very welcoming very much a
collaborative team effort
everybody felt heard and valued i really
looking back it's probably one of the
movies in terms of making it that i'm
the most fond of
so basically you're saying you would
work with her again i hope to i really
hope to even if it's not
acting opposite but i hope that i would
be in a film that she produces it was
excellent yeah
uh before i
run out of time i'm a big fan of william
monahan and i know that you are in
marlow which is neil jordan's movie um
can you sort of tease what that what
that what people can look forward to
with that
it was fun as a period movie uh i'd
worked with liam neeson before so it was
fun to
meet him again and have you ever met
neil jordan like him and
and liam are forced to be reckoned with
i have not seen the two of them together
uh with the way you have
yeah i think um you know neil is is very
eccentric
in the best
way um
and it was a challenging movie for all
the reasons you know making a period
movie is always challenging but
i had a lot of fun
we should i just finished it actually uh
coming back from dublin
so i don't know i haven't seen anything
you know but
sure i i i'm very excited for that one
um and also you're doing swimming with
sharks
that's finished that should be coming
out hopefully it should be coming out
sometime this year
i'm looking forward to seeing that
listen congrats on the 355 and uh i wish
you nothing but the best thank you so
much
you